first time of course it is
i'm a good kid pixar has another hit on
their hands with luca
and just like every other pixar film
it's chocked full of hidden details
whether it be keeping their traditions
of the pizza planet truck alive
calling back previous disney classics or
even hinting at what's to come from the
studio
pixar never fails to keep audiences on
the hunt for references
their italian sea monster tale luca has
plenty of hidden references
so hop on your vespa and let's start
searching
there it is that's how we're gonna see
the world one of pixar's biggest
trademarks of their films stems from an
inside joke between the animation
studio's staff
the number a113 this number has appeared
as a license plate
graffiti and has even made itself part
of the plot in various pixar films
room a113 this is actually a callback to
a classroom at cal arts where many of
pixar's top animators got their start
the number can be seen in the final
scene of the film where alberto hands
luca a train ticket
so he can travel off to the city to go
to school with julia
if your eyes were getting a bit misty
during this scene you likely missed that
luca's ticket number
is a113 you can go to school
i can if the diver suit that both luca
and alberto wore during several scenes
of the movie looked more familiar to you
that's because you've likely seen it
before in another aquatic-themed pixar
movie
finding nemo the diver's helmet has the
exact
same design as the one where jacques the
shrimp resides in dr sherman's fish tank
it's fine i'm not human
thank goodness another pixar staple is
the luxo ball
the signature ball doesn't always appear
in its original form
as it has shown up in the form of a
shield a merit badge and a steering
wheel
during the film's climactic race scene
there's a blink and you'll miss it shot
of the yellow and blue striped ball in
its original form
lying on the rooftops of porto rosso wow
it's fast alberto's lighthouse bedroom
has plenty of hidden goodies for fans to
look for with one of them being a
callback to pixar's beloved 2008 sci-fi
film
wall-e the boot which wally used to
carry the plant
over the course of the film can be seen
lying underneath alberto's hammock
pretty cool right yeah luca also drops
some secret details to some more recent
pixar films
which we see in the scene where luca and
alberto are swimming to the shore of
porto rosso
one of the boats they swim past has the
name elena printed on it
this small detail is a reference to
abuelita elena
what did he say to you he was just
showing me his guitar
shame on you the pizza planet truck has
appeared in all but one of pixar's films
and is a call back to their seminal
movie
toy story the crew had to get creative
with making the vehicle
fit in with the film setting of 1950s
italy
classic human town pretty cool right the
animation team decided to remodel the
truck into a piago ape which makes its
appearance during the porteroso cup
sequence
isn't it great wall-e's boot wasn't the
only pixar throwback hidden in alberto's
room
if you look closely you'll notice a hat
residing near alberto's hammock which
looks
quite similar to the hat that carl
fredrickson wore during several scenes
in the pixar classic
up hi mr frederickson the hat wasn't the
only detail that harkens back to up
if you look closely during the scenes
taking place outside of the town
restaurant
you'll find a poster advertising a soda
drink and if you examine it even further
you'll notice that one of the bottle
caps on the poster
shares a striking resemblance to the
grape soda bottle cap that ellie gave
carl in the beginning of up
we're in a club now donald duck is one
of the mouse house's most famous
and treasured characters in this scene
taking place in julia's bedroom
a plush toy resembling the classic
donald duck design sits by the foot of
the bed in one of the film's
easier to catch references one of the
two other secret details hidden in
julia's bedroom
is a copy of the original pinocchio book
titled le avencho
di pinocchio this isn't just a reference
to the disney animated classic
it's also a direct allusion to the
book's italian author carlo colotti
which ties directly into the film's
italian riviera theme
the second of two pinocchio cameos takes
place during a dream sequence
where luka envisions him and julia
flying over portoroso before the camera
pans down to reveal pinocchio waltzing
through the italian streets alongside
the lame fox
and the blind cat this also could be
tied to the fact that
in their respective films both luca and
pinocchio dream of being a real boy
i'm a real boy the train sequence had
several other secret features including
the number 04608
on the front of the train that luca and
julia depart on
that number isn't just any old random
number it's actually the zip code of
pixar's animated studio
come on roberto the train's gonna leave
pixar
sure does love their numerical
references and they took advantage of
the opportunities presented by the
film's finale
in yet another fun detail you can see
the number
1200 pa by the train doors which
actually refers to the studio's street
address
1200 park avenue in the streets of
porteroso you'll also be able to find
posters
advertising many films stemming from
classic italian cinema
but one of the posters is a callback to
one of disney's most famous aquatic
themed movies
20 000 leagues under the sea which
followed a team of deep sea explorers on
the search for
you guessed it sea monsters watch out
luca
everyone in porto rossa pretends to
believe in sea monsters
an album cover with the name nicolo
pietra can be found in julia's room
while casual audiences might not think
twice about the name hardcore pixar fans
might catch that this is a reference to
pixar animator and voice-over artist
nick pitera who initially got his start
making pixar themed music videos on
youtube and eventually went on to work
for the studio
pretty awesome pretty cool he even
provided his voice for the triple dent
gum jingle from inside out
one of pixar's traditions is to have the
directors of their films voice a
character in their own film
brad bird voiced edna mode in the
incredibles while pete doctor supplied
his vocals to kevin
in up just to name a few luca's director
enrico casarosa provided his voice to
the unnamed mustache man wearing a cap
who can be found sitting at a table in
some of the film's town square sequences
also included allusions to his first
pixar short film
la luna julia's father massimo closely
resembles the fatherly figure in la luna
and both films have plot lines that deal
with a child's curiosity about the stars
to top that off the main child from la
luna makes an appearance as a drawing in
the end credits
alberto i'm coming for you another
allusion to a pixar short film appears
in a climactic moment in the race
sequence where alberto
rushes to luca holding a blue umbrella
to protect his true identity
the pairing of alberto's soul blue
umbrella amongst an ocean of less
colorful umbrellas appears to be a
visual nod to the 2013 short film
the blue umbrella which features the
eponymous item amongst a swarm of gray
umbrellas
what's that it's just the greatest thing
that humans ever made
the vespa hidden mickeys have become a
trademark of disney's
lucca has one of its own albeit its
origins are a bit different
when animating the dream sequence
following luca and alberto riding a
vespa
casarosa and his crew noticed that one
of the cloud formations resembled a
hidden mickey
thus they decided to keep the hidden
mickey clouds in the film
i am marco visconti five-time winner of
the porto rosso cup
a potential ratatouille reference can be
seen during aircollar visconti's
entrance as air collate and his lackeys
sit outside of a restaurant you might
catch the restaurant's name
gustosa this is most likely a reference
to the famous chef gusto from
ratatouille
who owned the restaurant at the heart of
the story in ratatouille
who wants to watch me eat a big sandwich
luca continues pixar's trend of
providing a visual scavenger hunt for
film fans all across the world
enrico casorosa has even confirmed that
there is a hidden reference to pixar's
next film turning red
have you spotted it yet what was your
favorite disney reference in lucca